can any of you explain this tweet was
sent to the show hey I hope you are
happy with yourselves been looking
forward to this right this is Thomas so
which of you knows Thomas you so what's
your name
um I'm Jessica Jessica and why is Thomas
upset with us um Thomas is upset because
I've postponed a date for the second
time so I could come and be here you see
your boyfriend no no we have not been on
a date yes thank you so you put him up
why did you put him off for the first
time my sister and this time Kylie's
okay you know that book not that into
you
I haven't are you into him I don't know
not that into him she's come on what can
I suggest you take him out tomorrow
night when this is on
this week's visit to the red chair
that's where we go hello who's there
hello sir hello what's your name Thomas
okay and where are you from I'm from
Durham Durham alright but you live here
now
yes okay very good off you go over this
story Thomas uh so I asked a girl uh a
couple of weeks ago and she said yes
which was great because she's scheduled
tonight I thought it'd come down and see
if she wanted to rearrange for next week
yes I was your very key but she's given
you no indication to tease well I guess
he didn't look the good thing is he
didn't make other plans
that's good yeah okay so so this is your
decision now this is you this is you
sending a message to him so Jessica are
we going to flip Thomas you're we gonna
let Thomas war this is all okay Kiley
please will you leave him off the road
channel
literally dumped I think never even ones
on a date in you got dumb oh oh he's
gonna be
restaurant
is this the restaurant I smell Italian
food so you had a hag dude I had a hag
do in Spain and once the demon scene I
had doing a stag do
haggis camper